[Musik]
hier wird die zukunft des schweizer
käses neu gestaltet aus der nähe von
bern kommen vegane versionen von fondue
und co und das alles ohne milch die
basis bilden cashewkerne die firma new
rules in oberdiessbach produziert jeden
monat rund
150.000 stück veganer käse alternativen
ich denke ich dass es die zukunft erst
weil es einfach wir müssen uns
umorientieren und das ist einfach die
evolution des menschen
2015 gründet freddy hunziker sein
eigenes unternehmen mit gerade 21 jahren
käse darf er seine commerce und acht
weitere vegane sorgten nicht nennen weil
sie keine tiere milch enthalten die
schweizer käser kunst kommt aber auch
hier zum einsatz
dann werden sie hier über zwei bis drei
wochen eingelagert
[Musik]
abwechslung vom alltag und erholung
sucht freddy hunziker in den bergen
nebenan sein leben verändert sich 2015
schlagartig er will profi biker werden
doch ein unfall zerstört seine
karrierepläne in dieser zeit setzt er
sich mehr regeneration und vegane
ernährung auseinander und entwickelt
seine gründer idee
durch den sport wurde ich sicherlich
ziemlich diszipliniert auch durch das
ganze training die ganze
herausforderungen in sachen einem
wettkampf auch teilzunehmen und das hat
mir einen sich einen guten leben 2
gezeigt wird im unternehmen tomb raider
zu sein
aus seiner idee ist ein unternehmen mit
25 mitarbeitern geworden
wichtig ist im team das cashewkerne
weniger co2 als milchprodukte erzeugen
auch wenn sie aus übersee kommen
die herstellungsart eines rohstoffes ist
eigentlich eines der wichtigsten teilen
in punkto co2 bilanz bundeskasse kennen
wachsen auf nachreichen böden ohne das
wasser dazu gesetzt werden muss ist das
einzige negative ist dann eigentlich der
ganze transport der rund jetzt in punkto
co2 bilanz fünf prozent dazu zahlt das
ist eigentlich ein sehr kleiner
bruchteil auch in anderen teilen des
landes wird die traditionelle käse kunst
auf den kopf gestellt in genf im
französischsprachigen teil der schweiz
eröffnet 2017 die krimi wegen einer der
ersten leben in der metropole die
veganer alternativen zu milchprodukten
anbietet cashewkerne bilden auch hier
die basis in dem kleinen
familienunternehmen werden in handarbeit
neuen sorten hergestellt darunter
veganer alternativen von klassikern wie
ziegenkäse welchen camembert und grüne
hartkäse
2,6 prozent der schweizer sind veganer
doch nicht nur sie suchen den laden auf
das sind immer mehr menschen vertragen
milchprodukte nicht diese vor allem
haben wir flexitarier und alles esser
die zwar etwas verändern wollen die
etwas besser machen wollen in die aber
noch nicht bereit sind den ganz großen
schritt zu wagen
zurück in oberdiessbach im berner
mittelland im deutschsprachigen teil der
schweiz können die schweizer vom
geschmack her veganen von normalem käse
aus milch unterscheiden
[Musik]
leichter käse geschmack
ein bisschen kräuter
und dann hört sie auf um noch mehr zu
überzeugen arbeiten freddy hunziker und
sein team an der veganen variante des
schweizer schmelzkäse kohls dem von die
[Musik]
ja wir uns war ein foto von großer
wichtigkeit war endlich einen schweizer
traditionelles schweizer von die
begriffe
die schweizer tradition das handwerk
einstellt
ein ziel der alternativen käsehersteller
ist es auch nicht veganer anzusprechen
um eine ethische gesündere und
nachhaltigere möglichkeit als kuhmilch
aufzuzeigen
vielleicht ein käse der zukunft nicht
nur im alten land schweiz
[Musik]